Salut.
Il y a quelques semaines, au mois de décembre,
Thomas, de la chaîne Taupe10,
est venu sur ma chaîne
et m'a fait un tour.
Un tour de magie.
Qui m'a particulièrement gonflé.
Un peu énervé.
Tu vois, là je suis énervé par exemple.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo,
je vous laisse la regarder.
Je vous mets le lien dans
la description.
Je vais vous caler le lien
à ce moment là précis.
Il a fait un ACAAN :
Any Card At Any Number.
Il s'est passé un truc,
d'énorme !
On a parlé de ce tour sur Internet,
sur les forums de magie,
en cherchant l'explication
sans la trouver.
J'ai aussi, de mon côté,
cherché l'explication partout.
Vous avez vu ? Rien à voir,
mais on va bientôt être 400.000 ici,
sur cette chaîne !
Merci.
Abonnez-vous.
Il y a eu des messages
dans les commentaires
disant que j'étais complice...
Ce qui est complétement faux.
Avec une théorie du complot
comme quoi la vidéo fait 7 minutes 22
et que j'ai choisi le 7 de cœur
qui était en 22ème position...
Bref.
J'ai appelé Taupe 10,
une... une... euh...
une ou cinquante fois...
Je l'ai un petit peu harcelé,
parce que j'ai ma théorie,
en fait, sur le tour.
Et j'aimerais savoir
si c'est ça.
J'ai quand même un doute,
je suis sûr de moi à 90%
on va dire...
Donc il m'a dit :
"Il n'y a pas de problème Fabien,
je passe chez toi, je te refais le tour
et je te l'explique."
Énorme !
[Musique Générique]
Vous l'avez reconnu,
c'est l'auteur de tous ces méfaits,
c'est Monsieur Thomas,
alias Taupe10.
[Fab] Merci d'être là mec.
[Tom] De rien.
[Fab] Merci de revenir.
Alors, j'ai une théorie !
Je vais l'exposer.
Il y a un courant dans la magie,
et dans le mentalisme aussi, qui existe,
qu'on appelle le Jazz.
Qui est le fait de construire un tour,
avec, parfois, des beaux hasards
qui peuvent arriver...
et si ce beau hasard arrive,
t'arrête le tour ici.
[Tom] Ni vu, ni connu.
[Fab] Ni vu, ni connu.
[Fab] Donc d'après moi,
MA THÉORIE EST LA SUIVANTE !!!
Ma théorie c'est qu'il y avait
une suite à ce tour,
et qu'au moment où tu retourne
et que tu vois le 7 de cœur en bonne position,
[Fab] Tu te dis...
[Tom] Merde !!! Ça a marché !
[Fab]c'est bon... Hé bé, je m'arrête là.
[Fab] Et Bim j'ai bluffé Olicard.
Merci. Au revoir.
[Fab] Est-ce que ma théorie est correcte ?
[Tom] Et alors, attends...
Bien sûr, si ce n'est pas la bonne carte ?
[Fab] Et bé, pour moi tu as une suite.
si ce n'est pas la bonne carte,
tu t'arrête, etc... et tu dis...
[Tom] Combien de fois je tire une carte,
jusqu'à ce que ce soit la bonne ?
[Fab] Ah non !
Pour moi, après, il y a une vraie suite,
euh... peut-être en mode :
"Et là, regarde, maintenant cette carte
je vais faire ça..."
Pendant que tu fais ça,
toi tu fais autre chose.
Euh.... Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Qu'il y ait... euh...
un petit truc
"embrouille à Pipoland" !
[Tom] Ben, si tu as ton propre paquet...
[Fab] J'ai un paquet !
Le même que l'autre fois, mon gars.
[Tom] Le tour ne va pas bouger d'un yota.
[Fab] C'est un tout neuf.
Elles sont dans l'ordre.
[Tom] Dans le bon ordre.
[Fab] Pour le coup, veux-tu que
je les mélange un peu ?
[Tom] Il faut les mélanger !
Donc, euh...
[Fab] Parce qu'on m'a accusé
d'un cut sur un mélange,
mais sachez qu'il avait mélangé le jeu
et que je l'avais mélangé aussi.
Il n'y a pas de cut de je ne sais pas quoi,
[Tom] Je peux même me...
[Fab] Je suis le dernier mec
qui ferait en sorte qu'il
cache quelque chose sur cette chaîne.
[Tom] Ouais. C'est toi qui a fait le montage.
[Fab] Regardez, regardez.
Et là arrêtez de dire qu'il arrive
à tout mémoriser maintenant !
[Tom] Non. C'est compliqué, c'est petit.
Le retour est petit.
[Fab] Et je vais même re-mélanger derrière.
Et je coupe le jeu !
[Tom] D'accord.
[Tom] Et alors ? Dans le tour,
je ne sais pas si tu te souvenais,
[Tom] Je faisais un mélange à la française.
[Fab] Oui. Tout à fait.
[Tom] C'est important que j'ai, moi aussi,
mélangé le paquet à un moment donné.
[Fab] D'accord.
[Tom] Pas forcément que j'ai revu les cartes...
[Fab] Mais une seule ? ... Non...
[Tom] Non, euh... Même pas.
[Fab] Ben non ! C'est moi qui a choisi la carte !
[Fab] Oh, tu m'agaces...
[Tom] Donc...
[Tom] On va faire ça !
[Tom] Si tu souviens bien,
j'avais recoupé le paquet.
[Fab] Oui.
[Tom] On va le recouper.
[Fab] D'accord.
[Tom] Et là !
C'est là que le tour est fait, finalement...
[Fab] Ouais, mais tu n'as ni ma carte,
ni mon numéro à ce moment là...
[Tom] Oui, mais toutes les cartes sont
dans l'ordre qu'il faut pour que
quels que soient le numéro et
la carte que tu vas dire,
ça tombe bien.
[Tom] Tu comprends ?
[Fab]Nan.
[Tom] Quelle est ta carte aujourd'hui ?
[Fab] Le 5 de carreau.
[Tom] Quel est ton numéro ?
[Fab] Le... 11.
[Tom] Donc on va compter.
[Tom] On va recompter comme l'autre fois.
[Fab] Ouais.
[Tom] Je vais tout compter doucement,
parce que l'autre fois on m'avait dit que j'ai triché...
[Tom & Fab] Trois...
[Tom & Fab] Quatre...
[Tom & Fab] Cinq...
[Tom & Fab] Six... Sept...
[Tom & Fab] Huit... Neuf...
[Tom & Fab] Dix...
[Tom] Et celle là, c'est la onzième.
[Fab - approuvant] Hmm, hmm.
[Tom] Donc là, si c'est le 5 de carreau...
[Tom]J'aurais vraiment beaucoup de chance...
[Fab] Et oui !
[Fab] Là tu aurais beaucoup de chance !
[Tom] Ça serait improbable...
[Fab] Et ouais !
[Tom] Et bien effectivement,
c'est un tour que je réussis, en moyenne,
une fois sur cinquante-deux.
Parce qu'il n'y a même pas de suite
au tour.
[Fab] C'est vrai !?
[Fab] Oh pu**** !
[Tom] Le tour...
[Tom] Le tour, c'est...
une blague !
Où je dis, tout simplement :
Voilà, ce tour là, je le réussis...
[Fabien est explosé de rire]
[Tom] Une fois sur cinquante-deux.
[Tom] Mais !
[Tom] Quand il réussit,
il y a un effet de malade !
[Tom] Alors, la grosse chance
que j'ai eue,
[Fab] Parce que je l'ai vu au montage !
Je t'ai passé lentement,
et je trouvais que tu ne réagissais pas vite
au moment où tu avais
retourné la carte.
[Fab] Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
[Tom] Ben... t'es choqué !
[Fab] Je voyais la surprise
sur ton visage.
Je me suis dit :
Ce n'est pas possible...
[Tom] En fait, je me suis dit :
je vais lui faire une blague
je vais faire semblant que
je sais faire un tour,
et au moment où j'ai vu la carte
[Tom] Bon, j'étais choqué, dans ma tête.
[Fab] Ben oui !
[Tom] Mais je me suis dis :
Ok, enchaîne, enquille !
[Fab] Ben ouais...
[Tom] Faut que tu fasses croire que c'est vrai.
[Tom] Et voilà...
Je vous ai tous menti, je suis désolé.
[Fab] Ben non, tu n'as pas menti !
[Tom] Il n'y a pas de tour.
[Fab] Bé si, il y avait un tour !
[Fab] Il est exceptionnel.
[Fab] C'est le tour qu'on ne pouvait
pas expliquer.
[Tom] Si : il y a 1 chance sur 52.
Voilà, je le réussis.
[Fab] C'est génial.
[Tom] Mais alors, tu sais ce qui est très drôle ?
[Tom] C'est que, la veille, je l'ai fait à un collègue...
[Fab] Ouai.
[Tom] Et ça a marché aussi avec mon collègue.
[Fab] Oh pu****
[Fab] Deux fois d'affilé...
[Tom] On l'a tournée pour le 24,
[Fab] Ouais
A Noël, je l'ai refait à mon neveu...
[Fab] Ouais.
[Tom] Je l'ai retapé, à Noël,
devant toute la famille
j'ai retrouvé la carte !
Ça aurait été si beau que ça arrive
une deuxième fois !
[Fab] Merci Thomas.
[Tom] On peut tromper
mille fois, mille personnes...
non !
[Fab] Non.
[Tom] Mille...
[Fab] On peut tromper mille abonn... Non.
[Tom] Non.
[Fab] On peut 1 Youtube.
[Tom - riant] Ouais
[Fab] Tu vois...
[Tom - simultané] Tu vois ce que ça fait !
[Fab] Bé ouais.
[Tom] Je vous ai vengé, tous les abonnés
de Fabien qui en ont marre de tous ses tours.
[Tom] Au moins, il a vécu ça pendant 1 mois.
[Fab] Ce n'est pas une vengeance,
parce que tu m'as laissé le sentiment
d'émerveillement pendant un mois et demi.
[Fab] Et ça c'est...
[Tom] Tu as cru que j'étais vraiment magicien.
[Fab] Ouais.
[Tom] Ça se voyait,
je tremblais à moitié...
[Fab] C'est à dire que ma théorie,
j'y croyais à 90%.
[Tom] Ouais. Tu t'es dis :
Il a peut-être un truc de fou !
[Fab] Ouais.
Taupe10 ! Si vous ne connaissez pas,
ben c'est assez étonnant.
Alors foncez voir sa chaîne.
Vous regardez quelques vidéos,
et, assez naturellement,
vous allez avoir envie de vous abonner.
c'est comme ça.
C'est la vie de Taupe10.
Comme quoi mon intuition de départ
était la bonne,
ma théorie était la bonne.
Je l'avais dit dans les commentaires
et sur les forums de magie.
Personne ne me croyait.
J'étais sûr que c'était ça.
Enfin... sûr : non !
Comme d'habitude,
vous pouvez vous abonner
et si c'est déjà fait,  n'oubliez pas de cliquer
sur la petite cloche qui est en bas,
c'est important.
Et n'hésitez pas à me dire
quelle était, à vous, votre théorie
si vous aviez trouvé ou pas,
dans les commentaires.
A très bientôt.
Début de semaine prochaine.
Je crois que je vais préparer
du lourd...
Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]